[Musique]
jean marc jancovici bonsoir ça nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct
on voudrait avoir vos idées vos lumières
sur ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'énergie du climat de la taxe carbone
tout un tas de petits sujets comme ça
comment allez-vous d'à côté je suis
ignorant ce qui est un début comment ça
se passe au niveau de votre sujet à ce
que la population est sensible à ce que
vous nous racontez sur internet ça
dépend comment mesurer la sensibilité
trafic parce qu'il ya une masse de
population qui dans suffisamment
importante pour amener ce sujet devant
les politiques d'une façon concrète
non la réponse est non pour qu'un sujet
arrive devant les politiques en fait un
démocratie il faut que ça représente un
groupe de pression donc les gens qui
existent aux yeux des politiques c'est
soit les gens qui sont susceptibles de
faire voter pour quelqu'un d'autre soit
les gens qui sont susceptibles de
déplacer un morceau de l'économie voilà
c'est les gens qui représentent une
fraction suffisante de la société pour
être capable de dire si vous ne fait pas
plaisir ou si vous fait pas plaisir au
groupe que je représente
je m'énerve je monte les dents etc les
idées ne sont jamais dans cette
catégorie c'est à dire qu'on on acquiert
on a trait à jamais un politique et
sakho simplement avec des idées il faut
avoir une idée plus un moyen de pression
qu'il goûtera il est inexistant en
direct pour avoir un vrai moyen de
pression il faut être représentant
encore une fois d'un secteur économique
d'un syndicat d'une association qui a
pignon sur rue et qui est capable de
mobiliser les médias etc
moi je n'appartiens à aucune de ces
catégories si je regarde le nombre de
gens qui sont sur le toit pour prôner
prenez la page facebook des manuels
macron îles vierges pourquoi 500 milles
où un million de personnes qui suivent
mois sur la mienne et c'est déjà
beaucoup il y en a quinze mille donc
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui est
suffisant pour créer un débat de société
alors le débat de société vous souhaitez
l'année quelle est votre sujet à quoi
quels sont les risques
quelles sont les menaces par rapport
du moins est-ce que la population est
exposée à des menaces selon vous alors
je vais commencer par ne pas répondre à
la question et finir ce que j'avais
commencé
la seule manière pour moi de faire
exister le sujet que je porte c'est de
passer par des relais qui correspondent
à ce que j'ai expliqué juste avant c'est
à dire que si j'arrive à convaincre un
syndicaliste un chef d'entreprise d'une
grosse entreprise à représentant d'un
secteur économique que le fait de
s'occuper sérieusement du sujet que je
porte est quelque chose qui est
globalement bon pour lui à ce moment je
marque un point
parce que lui même fera valoir un
discours est beaucoup plus de force à
les tâches politiques
c'est comme ça que l'articulation se
passe lumineuse à sk des menaces alors
la réponse est oui sauf que pour le
moment on voit la partie sympathique de
la menace si je prends on pourrait
presque dire que l'énergie est une
drogue
c'est à dire que c'est quelque chose qui
dans un premier temps est très
sympathique
plus on en consomme plus et sympathique
sauf que les effets désagréables la
gueule le côté gueule de bois rivera
derrière alors le côté très sympathique
il arrive au début
depuis qu'on a commencé à taper dans
l'énergie fossile
on a augmenté la taille de la population
on a augmenté l'espérance de vie de la
population
on a augmenté le rayon d'action de
chacun peut aller plus loin plus vite
pour moins cher
on a augmenté la quantité de nourriture
à laquelle on a accès pour moins cher
on a augmenté notre pouvoir d'achat bref
pour le moment en première approximation
c'est que du bonheur
le problème c'est que l'expérience n'est
pas terminée et qu'une bonne partie de
ce que je viens de décrire se paye
derrière d'un certain nombre de factures
dont l'effet est pas instantané alors il
y en a une à laquelle on peut penser ces
changements climatiques mais pas que le
fait qu'on soit très nombreux sur terre
par exemple ce qui a été permis par
l'énergie a engendré de la déforestation
puisque pour nourrir tout ce beau monde
il faut faire des champs et les chants
se font en prenant sur la forêt on a
commencé à taper tellement dans les
stocks de poissons sur une partie des
stocks de poissons a diminué et c'est
donc il ya un certain nombre de choses
qu'on a mise en mouvement aujourd'hui et
dont les effets désagréables arriveront
ont commencé à arriver et vont augmenter
avec le temps
donc il ya une forme de menace à ce
titre est ce que la population s'en rend
compte
probablement plus qu'on ne le pense de
façon un peu diffuse est-ce qu'elle s'en
rend suffisamment comté est ce que c'est
suffisamment roues dans ses priorités
pour qu'elle accepte d'arrêter de vivre
vite quelque part c'est à dire de
profiter
tout temps qu'on en a et on verra
ensuite pour plus tard ça c'est pas
complètement certain ce que vous pensez
que l'idéologie à l'américaine est pour
quelque chose
je pense que les américains ont
l'idéologie de leur géographie c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont pas d'abord commencé
par avoir des idéologies qu'ils ont
qu'ensuite ils ont mises en oeuvre je
pense que l'idéologie qui l'on est le
résultat de ce que sont les états unis
et les états unis c'est quoi c'est une
terre de liberté pour des colons venant
d'europe qui étaient pour une large part
oppressé c'est un endroit c'est dolan of
plenty enfin je veux dire c'est
l'endroit où on a tout ce qu'on veut à
profusion donc il ya de l'or des bisons
des forêts des terres cultivables des
fruits des arbres
enfin je veux dire no limits coincé et
donc les états unis ils ont fait un
peuple à cette image
du reste le système politique américain
est le système le moins contraignant qui
soit se taire que l'état fédéral aux
états unis on lui a donné trois 3
mandats sécuritaire c'est déjà sur la
sécurité intérieure
donc tous les gens vous adorez le russe
chinois cia et le fbi et c'est donc des
gens qui s'occupent de la sécurité
intérieure je m'occupe de la sécurité
extérieure l'armée et je m'occupe de la
sécurité économique c'est-à-dire la
monnaie et puis pour le reste surtout
que je ne m'occupe de rien voilà donc le
mandat qu'on a donné à l'état fédéral
aux etats-unis c'est surtout de ne
s'occuper de rien et c'est à l'image de
ce qu'elle pays où les ressources sont
tellement abondante que chacun porte
avec lui le credo qui peut se
débrouiller tout seul parce qu'il peut
avoir accès tout seul le colon est venue
du fait qu'il y avait plein de choses
plein d'autres choses suffisait juste de
tuer quelques audiences mais à part ça
il y avait tout ce qu'on voulait donc le
l'américain il a fait un système qui est
à son image et donc il a fait une
idéologie qui était à l'image de ce qui
était physiquement les etats unis c'est
bien dans ce sens là que les choses se
sont passées la propagation de
l'american way of life par exemple aux
chinois savoir quelles implications sur
monde entier alors l'american way of
life comme je le disais c'est transposer
ailleurs le fait qu'on est dans un monde
sans limites puisque c'était ça
physiquement
l'univers dans lequel l'américain a
évolué a bien évidemment le monde n'est
pas sans limites le monde a des limites
il a des limites partout sauf que les
etats-unis les ont touchés plus tard que
les autres
en europe on avait touché les limites
avant l'europe était plus densément
peuplées on a achevé la déforestation en
europe en 1850
on avait déjà en europe dans certains
endroits des problèmes d'accès aux
ressources naturelles donc l'american
way of life ça a été les limites
arrivent plus tard elles sont elles sont
plus loin il faut savoir par exemple
qu'en 1939 70 % de la production
mondiale de pétrole était américaine
donc ça l'europe et avait déjà elle
passait son pic d'extraction de charbon
en grand-bretagne pardon et en france
mais en bretagne
donc le donc le l'american way of life
exporté ailleurs ça veut dire faites
comme nous utiliser toutes les
ressources que vous arrivez à trouver
sans vous imposer de limites et
évidemment que ça butera plus vite
ailleurs que chez eux alors en chine
ils ont isolé ils en ont profité on va
dire pendant 30 ans commence déjà à
buter sur des limites ce qui se rabat en
plus sur la mer de chine nommé dès lors
qu'auront 7 ou 9 stress est simple quand
on ne ferait alors moi je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de la géopolitique chinoise
par contre ce que je suis capable de
dire c'est que comme le carburant de
l'économie industrielle c'est l'énergie
les chinois aujourd'hui ils sont déjà
pas très loin d'être en butée sur leur
croissance leur approvisionnement
pétrolier n'augmente plus à la vitesse à
laquelle il augmentait jusqu'à
maintenant il ya des questions qui
commencent à se poser sur leur
approvisionnement charbonnier les
tendances sont trop enfin c'est sur un
nombre d'années trop court pour que l'on
puisse commencer en tirer des
conclusions
par contre il commence vraiment à avoir
des caisses des problèmes sur la
quantité de terres cultivables et sur
les rendements agricoles
donc ils commencent à arriver eux aussi
en butée et s'est pas totalement au
hasard pour moi si les chinois sont en
train de s'emparer très fortement de la
question environnementale
parce que je pense qu'ils sont vraiment
en train de se rendre compte
qu'ils sont à venir la croissance
chinoise à deux chiffres et même à un
chiffre je ne pense pas qu'elle va
continuer pendant un temps le mix
énergétique se doit vous parlez le mix
énergétique dans dix ans on aura quoi
votre vie alors le mix énergétique
mondial aujourd'hui est dominé à 80% par
les combustibles fossiles et si je fais
course et 30% en pétrole
un peu moins de 30% en charbon et un peu
plus de 20% en gaz c'est ça les trois
énergies rennes dans le monde
aujourd'hui l'énergie qui a le plus
augmenté sur les dix dernières années
c'est le charbon en valeur absolue donc
l'énergie le mix énergétique mondial
dans dix ans il est encore dominée par
les combustibles fossiles quoi qu'on
fasse
si on est raisonnable sur le climat on
consommera moins d'énergie mais ça sera
toujours de manière dominante des
énergies fossiles
si on n'est pas raisonnable sur le
climat est qu on a encore suffisamment
de stocks on consommera plus d'énergie
fossile et ça sera surtout plus de gaz
et de charbon parce que le pétrole on
n'est pas très loin du maximum mais
voilà ça il y aura pas de basculement
rapide sur autre chose dans les dix ans
qui viennent une percussion sur
l'économie la répercussion sur
l'économie il faut rappeler le rôle de
l'énergie dans l'économie en fait
l'énergie c'est par définition la
formation d'un flux physiques ça
l'énergie toc l'énergie ça c'est
raconter un flux physiques
or l'économie ça sert à créer des flux
physiques
quand je transforme du minerai de fer en
faire c'est un flux physiques quand je
transforme on faire en boulons de 12 c
d'où un flux physiques et quand je
transforme tout un tas d'éléments dans
la caméra qui est en train de me filmer
je fais aussi des flux physiques donc et
puis quand derrière je transporte le
meuble que j'ai fabriqué entre le
magasin le lusine de meubles et le
magasin où je vais aller l'acheter même
en kit c'est encore un flux physiques
quand je déplace le consommateur en
voiture jusqu'au magasin c'est encore un
flux physiques donc l'économie allait
baser sur des flux physiques plus j'ai
d'énergie à mettre dans le système plus
je suis capable de faire fonctionner
deux machines parce que la meule énergie
en fait c'est le fonctionnement d'une
machine est donc plus je suis capable de
créer de flux physiques
donc il ya un lien inexorable entre la
production économique on se reçoit on
l'entend habituellement en mesure et en
euros et la quantité d'énergie qu'on met
dans le système c'est à dire la quantité
de machines qu'on met ans
mouvement pour produire ces flux
physiques qui auront une contrepartie en
euros ce qui veut dire que dans le
système dans lequel on vit on n'a pas
trouvé le moyen de baisser
significativement la consommation
d'énergie sans contracter
significativement l'économie
on sait pas faire ça qu'est ce qui se
passe quand l'économie se contracte dont
le poste est que si c est bien dans le
passé c'est pas le passé c'est les dix
dernières années en fait il se trouve
que l'approvisionnement énergétique dans
ce qu'on appelle la zone ocde
c'est à dire qu'on appelle encore
classiquement les pays riches
sauf que même les pays pauvres
aujourd'hui sont très riches par rapport
aux paysans du moyen-âge mais
rappelons-le est quand même les pays
riches et les pays de l' ocde
donc toute l'europe l'amérique du nord
le mexique etc japon dans cette zone là
l'approvisionnement énergétique globale
est passée par un maximum en 2006 donc
ça fait dix ans qu'on a passé le maximum
11 ans même et ça a commencé à décliner
derrière et c'est parce que cet
approvisionnement a décliné que la
croissance économique a commencé à
ralentir dans ces zones là que ça a créé
aux états unis un problème de
retournement des prix de l'immobilier
qui lui même a engendré la crise
financière que l'on sait donc c'est bien
la crise énergétique qui a déclenché la
crise financière
donc ça c'est une première conséquence
très concrète de la crise économique qui
s'est transmis la terre d'europe qui
s'est traduite par une baisse du nombre
d'emplois
alors pourquoi est ce que quand
l'approvisionnement énergétique baisse
le nombre d'emplois baisse c'est assez
simple c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas un emploi qu'ils puissent se
passer d'une machine personne qui est
derrière la caméra là a besoin d'une
machine si je supprime sa caméra je lui
supprime son emploi moi j'ai besoin de
machines pour fonctionner même si je
suis consultant j'ai besoin d'un métro
pour m'amener à mes rendez vous j'ai
besoin d'un ordinateur pour marcher de
temps en temps j'ai besoin d'un
ascenseur pour monter au 30e étage de la
tour où j'irai voir quelqu'un donc
téléfoot pour produire que vous êtes en
retard jamais donc depuis peu un
téléphone qui me sert parfois après le
dire que je suis en retard mais ça c'est
pas indispensable pour faire mon boulot
par contre le métro beaucoup plus et
l'ascenseur pour monter au 30e étage de
la tour
il est aussi quelque part et
l'ordinateur encore plus avec le métier
que je fais donc je suis totalement
dépendant de machines le conducteur de
bus il est dépendant d'une machine c'est
le bus et même le fabricant de foie gras
il est dépendant de tout un tas de
machines pour faire les aliments pour
ses canards pour bouillir les x fin pour
cuire les fois pour fabriquer des bocaux
dans lesquelles ils allaient mettre
enfin donc on est tous dépendants de
machines partir du moment où je
contracte l'approvisionnement
énergétique les moins de machines qui
travaillent et donc j'ai besoin de moins
de monde pour piloter les machines et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
tous les pays industrialisés quand je
contracte rapidement l'approvisionnement
énergétique je vais sans emploi c'est ce
qu'on a constaté dans tous les pays ocde
après 2006 où on a vu le chômage
augmenter et dans les pays qui
aujourd'hui ont apparemment résorber une
partie de leur chômage notamment les
états unis
en fait si on regarde la fraction de la
population qui occupent un emploi
elle est aujourd'hui inférieure encore à
ce qu'elle était en 2000 et une partie
de ces emplois sont des emplois plus mal
payés que ce qu'on avait en 2000 donc le
le donc la conséquence d'un d'une
contraction de l'approvisionnement
énergétique dans un pays qui est devenu
tellement dépendants des machines pour
assurer sa production économique
on la voit déjà autour de nous c'est une
augmentation du chômage c'est une
augmentation de la pauvreté
c'est une augmentation du vote populiste
qui s'appelle trump marine le pen y cite
c'est les mêmes expressions on va dire
dans les urnes venant de gens qui sont à
peu près dans les mêmes couches sociales
habitant à peu près au même endroit et
vivent le même genre de déception pour
résumer trivialement c'est trop de
signes plus de foin dans les râteliers
les chevaux se bat alors quand pour
quand il n'ya plus de foin dans leur
atelier de la machine le cheval qui
dépendait de la machine se bat
effectivement c'est exactement ça sauf
que c'est pas notre nourriture à nous
qui est en cause aujourd'hui c'est la
nourriture des machines qui nous permet
d'avoir ce pouvoir d'achat à profusion
et 7,7 ce système économique à profusion
beaucoup de responsables économiques y
ait beaucoup de responsables politiques
à la suite font une erreur de lecture
derrière en disant il ya qu'à prendre
les bonnes mesures et l'économie
repartira à la hausse moi je crois que
malheureusement c'est pas ça qui va se
passer
et du coup je pense qu'il va falloir
apprendre à vivre avec une économie qui
se contracte de manière structurelle en
termes physiques sens que ce thonier
sens castanier et je pense que l'enjeu
il est là aujourd'hui je pense que le
jus de cerveau on devrait l'investir
dans comme enjeu résout ce problème
eux et non pas comment je prend les
bonnes mesures de chez pas quoi et je
vais libérer la croissance
c'est du reste axé cocasse de se
rappeler que attali avait été chargé en
2008 d'une commission pour libérer la
croissance et que manifestement pas été
très probants mais il n'y pouvait rien
il se battait contre la contraction du
flux physiques
le vrai problème qu'on a dans cette
affaire c'est un problème et c'est là
que je vais en venir à mon sujet c'est
qu'on a un problème de mauvais tableau
de bord c'est à dire que on a inventé un
système économique dans lequel n'y a pas
la physique depuis deux siècles on a
considéré que la physique avait rien à
faire dans le système économique
on a postulé il ya deux siècles dans
l'économie classique que les ressources
naturelles ça vaudrait 0
l'énergie est une ressource naturelle
parmi d'autres salons et donc dans le
système qu'on a conceptualisé on
s'occupe que des hommes et du capital
humain et le reste n'a pas d'importance
sauf que évidemment si je mets des
hommes et une usine flambant neuf au
milieu du vide intersidéral sans
l'énergie pense que la production s'est
excusé moi vous couper si le tableau de
bord qui est pipée où c'est celui qui
regarde le tableau de bord qui donc des
niches mais les deux mon général parce
que une fois qu'on arrive une fois quand
à pendant deux siècles fournit un
tableau de bord qui était mauvais on
peut pas reprocher à la population de se
prendre au jeu
pendant longtemps on a brûlé les
sorcières en pensant que ça allait
améliorer le sort de la population qui
dans cette affaire était responsable un
peu tout le monde
bon donc là c'est là c'est exactement
pareil j'ai envie de dire le fait de
brûler la sorcière aujourd'hui c'est
croire que la physique n'a pas de rôle
dans l'économie
bon une croyance collective ce que si on
accepte l'idée que la physique et un
rôle on accepte ce qui va derrière c'est
à dire que l'économie va se contracter
et donc on accepte que l'on va devoir
plutôt serré un peu les coudes que
chacun profite et de plus en plus c'est
très compliqué du coup ce système là je
vais prendre quelques exemples
sauf que je dirais une entreprise en ce
moment on a nos entretiens annuels
d'évaluation
tous ils demandent une augmentation bon
sauf que si j'ai un jeu à somme nulle
cercle pib n'augmente plus si je leur
donne leur augmentation
quelque part j'ai su priver le boulot de
quelqu'un ailleurs est ce que je peux
leur répondre ça non bon j'avais
l'entendre ils font pas de dire par
solidarité avec les gens qui voudraient
un boulot ailleurs on va accepter de ne
pas avoir d'augmentation donc cesser
c'est enfin je dis ça va chercher très
loin ce que je suis en train de dire le
fait de remettre en question le système
c'est très perturbant
sur plein de choses qui sont considérés
aujourd'hui comme acquise la caste
politique on va les pauvres ils saluent
un pull et rhabillé pour l'hiver
ils sont bien au courant de ce qui se
passe ils sont bien au courant ils ont
bien des services de renseignements
qu'ils étudiaient tu pas là dessus ils
ont bien des services de renseignements
qui leur dit voilà il fallait se
déployer un petit peu par la sécuriser
notre approvisionnement énergétique
alors oui sauf que sécuriser
l'approvisionnement énergétique ont fait
pas nécessairement le lien avec le fait
que le jeu donne quelques exemples avec
le fait que l'énergie va augmenter ou
décroître alors je vais prendre quelques
exemples
je pense qu'il n'y a pas on va prendre
un débat emblématique dans ce pays qui
est nucléaire n'en voyez je vais dire
tout de suite
aujourd'hui si on supprime une partie de
la production nucléaire
quelques règles de trois pas très
compliqué à faire sur ce que ça coûte de
remplacer le nucléaire par un système
complet avec à la fois les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires et la sécurité
d'approvisionnement qui va derrière sur
la garantie que le train de 8 heures
partira bien à 8 heures même si a pas de
vent et bien le coût complet de cette
affaire c'est un multiple des
investissements même très cher dont on a
besoin pour refaire du nucléaire là où
j'ai besoin de mettre un milliard sur la
table pour refaire du nucléaire même si
c'est très cher je dépasse les budgets
j'ai plutôt besoin de 5 à 10 si je veux
la même quantité d'électricité avec des
modes intermittents plus du stockage
comme cet argent on va pas l'avoir pour
prendre un exemple l'allemagne a déjà
dépensé quelques centaines de milliards
d'euros dans cette transition
énergétique et eux ils ont 200 milliards
d'euros de solde exportateur par an donc
ils peuvent se permettre ce genre de
caprice beaucoup plus que nous
comme cet argent on l'aura pas si on
décide de supprimer rapidement tout un
tas de réacteurs nucléaires on va
essentiellement les remplacer par rien
jambes ou non on l'a pas non plus on n'a
pas pas rien du coup on va contracter
rapidement l'approvisionnement arrière
électriques et du coup on va contracter
une partie des flux physiques qui en
dépendent donc il y aura moins de trains
qui arrivent à l'heure - des usines
d'aluminium qui pourront électrolyse et
l'aluminium et c'est donc la production
économique va se contracter
bon aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas une
personne parmi des avocats de la baisse
rapide du nucléaire qui dit pas de
problème j'ai bien compris la
contrepartie quiconque remplacera ça
passera par des nerfs kilowattheures par
kilowattheure jelloun renouvelables et 2
1 et 2 que du coup je dis délibérément
que j'avais contracté la production
économique est là pour penser ça donc et
non pas parce que ils sont stupides mais
juste parce que envie de perdre leur
place
c'est même pas ça l'occasion qu'ils ont
de comprendre ça n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas dans les circuits
institutionnels ça existe pas dans les
gens dont il s'entoure ça il a fait ça
n'existe pas vous faites bien des
conférences à gaujac comment il n'y a
pas de politique je mais s'il ya des
politiques de terrain dont vous avez des
élus locaux qu'il nous faut des nous
démerder
je vais pas les noms en tête mais je
veux dire quand je fais une conférence
quelque part il arrive que l'adjoint au
maire vienne ou même le maire si c'est
une petite ville où etc
mais c'est des élus locaux vous avez une
vidéo de votre serviteur qui tourne sur
internet qui concerne une audition que
j'avais eu à l'assemblée nationale
devant la commission du développement
durable c'est que tron il ya quelques
années je suis à un âge où on confronte
vu exactement ça en a fait à peine 150
mille donc je suis un âne jardin
comparés à n'importe quel 20h de
n'importe quelle chaîne de télévision
nationale et surtout si vous allez
regarder les questions composé des
députés derrière vous avez une question
sur deux qui n'est absolument pas la
question que poserait l'honnête homme ou
là des deux femmes qui a juste envie de
comprendre un truc qui n'a pas compris
ou qui a envie de réagir mais toujours
de manière honnête j'ai envie de dire
par rapport à quelque chose que j'ai dit
ils sont là pour la galerie savent
qu'ils sont filmés donc il se rendre
intéressant en posant une question qui
était écrit time que j'ai démarré mon
intervention il roucoule oui on peut
dire ça comme ça bon et on va revenir
sur le nucléaire comme on est un peu
pressés par le temps parce que on à
périco légasse qui arrive un peu moi
j'aimerais sortir du nucléaire le parce
que j'en ai parlé j'aurais parlé après
du pétrole le pétrole qui est le système
mondial de transport
il ya encore moins de gens dans le monde
politique qui ont compris que
l'approvisionnement français en pétrole
désormais étaient orientés à la baisse
il faut vous immoler devons lieu l'isi
aucune envie de me voler devant l'elysée
n'ont maintenant ils ont mis des
barrières de sécurité
on va revenir sur le nucléaire vite fait
et donc les réserves d'uranium mondiale
ça donne quoi
ça baisse ça baisse pas est-ce que
l'accord avec les états unis entre les
etats-unis la russie le fait de
transmettre de transférer du nuc du de
l'uranium aux états unis cet accord est
devenu caduc oui ou non est ce qu il
reste par exemple le kazakhstan c'est le
dernier en arabie saoudite du nucléaire
où sont les réserves d'uranium
combien ça coûte de recharger
commun tonnes ça coûte du moins combien
de tonnes il faut pour recharger tous
les réacteurs ou du tout les recteurs
nouveau est ce qu'il y aura suffisamment
d'uranium pour recréer des réacteurs
l'aspect sécurité du nucléaire l'aspect
terroristes du nucléaire l'aspect
stockage des déchets le recyclage
on y va bigre alors d'abord je voudrais
arriver alors je vous laisse je vois ici
reconstruire le débat en rappelant que
leclerc c'est 15% de l'électricité
mondiale
cinq noms de l'électricité c'est à dire
selon la façon dont on compte entre 3 et
5% de l'énergie mondiale dit bien selon
la façon dont sont contre mais je vais
pas rentrer parce que l'électricité à
une comptabilité spécial ça ne change
rien à ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
80% ses défauts si les en disant 80% ce
sera toujours des fossiles le nucléaire
dans le contexte de ce que j'ai évoqué
juste avant alors ça peut paraître
étonnant à certaines personnes qui nous
écoutent mais c'est un moyen d'amortir
la décroissance c'est quoi c'est le
doliprane pour faire passer des films ou
si le disais à peu près ça c'est un
moyen d'amortir la décroissance c'est à
dire que comme on va de toute façon être
mis à la diète en europe sur les
combustibles fossiles qui eux par contre
sont tous structurellement orientés à la
baisse le pétrole le charbon le gaz
les trois sont en contraction
d'approvisionnement en europe et trois
essais structurelles si en plus on
abandonne le nucléaire on accélère la
décroissance donc dans mavs dans mon
point de vue à moi le nucléaire c'est un
amortisseur de la décroissance en même
temps que c'est un moyen de se passer du
charbon dans la production électrique
mais mais ça donc c'est bien comme ça
que le voient la deuxième chose que je
vais dire avant de répondre en détail
c'est que le nucléaire aujourd'hui
évident plus de risques qu'il n'en crée
donc tous les risques que les gens aux
ventes est pas votre avis c'est de dire
que je suis en train de vous donner dans
dans le
malgré ce que les gens auront en tête en
france mais c'est pas comme ça dans la
majeure partie des pays du monde
d'accord
donc c'est un syndrome un peu français
le syndrome de mettre un petit coup de
air lance roquettes anti char sur une
piscine de combustibles c'est un risque
envisageable oui mais si vous avez des
lance-roquettes anti-char vous pouvez
faire bien pire que d'aller les envoyer
sur une piscine de combustible alors il
ya des trucs que je dirais pas j'ai pas
envie de donner de bonnes idées à des
gens qui s'en emparer je suis très
sérieux quand je dis ça mais il ya bien
pire à faire c'est juste pas un problème
donc le le nucléaire aujourd'hui il est
l'objet
j'ose le mot de quelque chose qui relève
plus du fantasme que du débat éclairé je
pense qu'il n'y a pas une personne qui
nous écoutent sauf les gens qui
travaillent dans cette industrie qui
savent très exactement quels sont les
éléments qu'on trouve dans les déchets
nucléaire connaissait les éléments qu'on
trouve dans les déchets nucléaires
officieux nom des choses comme ça noront
patricia sommes nous serons six hommes
le césium dans l'est dans les produits
de fission vous avez dit oddo cie qui
est c'est enfin vous avez un certain
nombre de l'argon du xénon donc il ya
les gens savent pas ce que c'est des
gens savent pas ce que c'est qu'un
décret hl oui donc d'en être donc on est
vraiment dans le débat affectif c'est
avec les tripes je reviendrai ici j'ai
rencontré des gamins qui revenait d'un
camp de vacances pour aller mieux subir
les radiations qu'ils ont reçue il ya
très longtemps j'ai pas compris les
enfants de tchernobyl
oui l'ex union soviétique la russie
continue de les envoyer en vacances de
temps en temps oui ça relève du fantasme
les séquelles jeu je vois pas exactement
de quoi on parle
td des siens l'accident nucléaire le
risque les risques pour la population la
chaux l'environnement le risque pour la
population aujourd'hui si un accident
c'est celui d'évacuation à fukushima par
exemple l'évacuation a fait des
centaines de morts à cause du stress
si les gens étaient restés sur place les
radiations on aurait fait zéro du
ralenti pardon un instant t non non non
dans la durée il ya un rapport qui a été
fait il faut savoir alors je sais pas si
vous savez il ya une commission des
nations unies qui s'appelle une star une
clients sonos non une star
qui a exactement le même rôle que le
giec sauf que le giec s'occupe du
changement climatique et eux s'occupent
de la question la radioactivité j'avais
vu dernier un reportage sur nucléaire
darty je me contrefous de savoir ce que
pense arte aucun média de mettre
opposable art et l amour de la théorie
du complot que je ne regarde jamais leur
reportage
ils ont sorti toutes les conneries qu'il
voulait sur le changement climatique
ils ont sorti un jeu de un joli nombre
de conneries sur le pétrole dont cartes
et ils ont un sur le thorium ils ont
fait l'exact inverse c'est à dire qu'ils
ont encensé le truc en disant que
c'était la martingale alors que c'est
pas du tout vrai enfin c'est pas du tout
vrai c'est une voie de pour faire du
nucléaire mais c'est pas le truc qui est
merveilleux par rapport à la voie qu'on
fait aujourd'hui donc arte ils ont un
parti pris sur ces sujets là qu'ils sont
on vous cache tout on vous dit rien oui
qui n'est absolument pas justifiée par
la qualité de l'information qui font
circuler derrière donc le pas de
l'argent du service public très
dépendantes soit bien dépensé
mais donc pour revenir à la question du
nucléaire dont vous avez une instance
onusienne qui a la même qualité de
production que le giec
cette instance a fait une compilation
sur fukushima parce que c'est ça qui
font comme le giec il faut une
compilation d'articles scientifiques
d'où il ressort que la dose qui a été
libérées dans l'environnement n'aura pas
d'effet sur l'environnement et
n'auraient pas eu d'effet sur les
populations s'il était resté là où il
était resté penser en termes de gens qui
écoutent vont se dire tout ça c'est les
vendus sait très bien qu'il le prouve
moi j'ai été lire le truc si on le
prouve dans 30 ans est-ce qu'on peut
venir vous chercher à manger mais on
peut ce public pas de problème
moi ce que je dis aujourd'hui c'est que
les gens qui sont contre le nucléaire à
croiser globalement le risque la
déstabilisation que court la planète
parce que il nous maintiennent plus
longtemps dans le charbon et que le
charbon ça fait du changement climatique
dont sert à faire des guerres ça va
faire des famines sert à faire des
émeutes ça va faire un raccourcissement
de l'espérance de vie
ça va faire d'acidification des océans
et de la perte de biodiversité et que si
je fais la somme de tout ça vraiment le
nucléaire n'empêche pas de dormir
voilà ça reste le nucléaire une
industrie dangereuse comme l'industrie
chimique comme le fait de conduire des
voitures et si je suis encore plus
provocant tant que les cigarettes sont
en vente libre je pense que c'est
vraiment pas le sujet de s'occuper du
nucléaire
provocant si ça peut être en france je
vous mettrais colonel liquidateur pour
les nettoyer tout ça alors si ça pète en
france ça ne fera pas de tchernobyl pour
une raison assez simple c'est que la
centrale n'est pas du tout la même
les les centrales françaises dont une
enceinte de confinement tchernobyl
n'avait pas qu'arnaud bill avait du
graphite dans le coeur ce qui a provoqué
un incendie et un panache qui est monté
très haut dans l'atmosphère les uns
centrales françaises n'ont pas une oie
du mox sa part donc du mox oui on a du
box mais ça n'a rien à voir avec saint
elix uranium plutonium se dit mais c'est
rien à voir avec ce qu'a fait l'accident
de tchernobyl
voilà donc je donc je le redit ma
conviction à prendre peut-être parler
d'autre chose ça vous intéresse ma
conviction sur le nucléaire c'est un le
nucléaire était un sujet compliqué
technique tripale ça fait appel à des
unités que personne ne comprend personne
ne sait ce que c'est qu'un millisieverts
tout un becquerel ça fait appel à un
processus qui est invisible
la radioactivité est le truc invisible
toujours plus peur que le truc visible
donc les gens ont plus peur du nucléaire
des accidents de voiture je vous assure
que moi pour mes gosses fait plus peur
des accidents de voiture que du
nucléaire est plus peur ou la cigarette
aussi le le nucléaire fait appel à un
truc que le français adorent qui est le
combat du gros contre le petit donc on
adore astérix tous moi le premier donc
quand le petit se bat contre l'euro le
petit à raison par principe donc la
petite ong environnementales qui se bat
contre le gros et df à notre affection
par principe donc s'accumulent tout un
tas de difficultés dans la discussion
qui rend le débat d'entrée de jeu
affectif et je suis très amusé de voir
les gens qu'ils m'expliquent qu'ils
n'ont pas confiance dans la presse se
baser sur ce qu'ils trouvent dans la
presse pour m'expliquer que le nucléaire
est une horreur
je prends l'exemple d'autres sites ong
greenpeace je vous verrai bien si tu es
arte tout à l'heure comment vous pouvez
bien citer arte tout à l'heure oui c'est
vraiment les médias quoi donc je vous
reprends sur une piste comme moi je vois
greenpeace c'est à dire trois pelés et
un tondu avec des dreadlocks retrait
dans une
c'est une boutade rentrer dans une
centrale nucléaire comme un peu comme
dans du beurre s'amuse à faire péter un
feu d'artifice au pied de la piscine de
stockage
si ça avait été un peu les un peu plus
énervé pour des questions idéologiques
kantienne piscine qui sautent qu'on peux
pas la remplir le risque est quand même
relativement important donc pas le
risque il est exactement celui qu'on a
eu à fukushima c'est à dire que vous
avez le combustible qui se ménage avoir
usé qui se met à chauffer ça vous fait
une espèce de magma et avoue contamine
le site et sa roue linge dans
l'atmosphère pas nécessairement
pas nécessairement non mais par exemple
si le mox commencé à dégager avec du
plutonium
c'est un gros risque d'un gros is la
demi vie du plutonium sait combien la
deuxième vie du plutonium est très
longue mais encore une fois il faut est
ce que vous savez de quand date le plus
vieux de stockage de déchets nucléaires
au monde
vous parlez codling oh non il a deux
milliards d'années encore le noyau
terrestre le soleil pas du tout au tout
il ya au gabon une mine d'uranium à au
clos donc là où il ya des trafics de
minerais cela je ne sais pas s'il ya des
trafics de minerais par contre je sais
qu'il ya un gisement d'uranium et dans
ce gisement d'uranium
il ya de l'uranium naturel qui contient
0 7 % d'uranium 235 ou piscine on
souffre non non on s'en fout pas du tout
parce que c'est comme disait l'autre
c'est peut-être votre question mais
c'est la réponse donc dans cet uranium
de 100 naturel ya 0 7 % d'uranium 235 il
sauf que l'uranium 235 a une demi vie de
700 millions d'années
donc il ya 700 millions d'années il y
avait pas 0,7 me 1,4
il ya un milliard et demi il n'y avait
pas 1,4 mais 2,8 et il ya deux milliards
d'années il y avait trois et demi
pourcent d'uranium 235 dans l'uranium
naturel c'est à dire très exactement le
taux d'uranium 235 dans l'uranium
enrichi qu'on vit aujourd'hui dans les
centrales donc j'ai ce gisement
d'uranium avec de l'uranium enrichi
naturel et puis j'ai des infiltrations
d'eau qui arrive parce que il ya de
l'eau qui s'infiltre depuis la surface
il sauf que quand vous mettez de
l'uranium à 3 25 % d'uranium 235 dans de
l'eau vous avez la réaction en chaîne
qui se déclenche donc la réaction en
chaîne se déclenche dans ce gisement
puis à 2 milliards d'années il n'y a pas
un homme pour vérifier que la sûreté est
bien respectée et il n'y a pas un homme
pour s'occuper de prendre les déchets
nucléaires et de les mettre ailleurs
et peut-être personne
cette population vous l'avez dit il y
avait personne
bon donc les déchets ont pas été gérée
et leurs descendants sont très
exactement là où ils ont été laissés
donc en ce qui concerne les déchets je
reviens à la hague moi j'ai une solution
très simple pour les déchets ont fait un
trou à 450 m de profondeur on les fout
dedans et on les oublie et karine et
pour les régler sauf que les mêmes qui
disent ah c'est très dangereux de les
laisser en surface à la hague sont
également les mêmes qui vous disent faut
surtout pas faire un trou pour les
mettre à 450 mètres de profondeur donc
en fait leur mandat c'est pas de trouver
une solution c'est de faire parler d'eux
en disant qu'ils sont contre le
nucléaire c'est ça leur mandat
greenpeace je vais faire quelque chose
qui est très déplacé mais je vais un peu
mon téléphone allô péricaud quelqu'un
qui va chercher dans quatre secondes
si ces systèmes c'est juste en face de
suite on continue désolé aux aléas du
direct
on va revenir à la taxe carbone
il reviendra sur nucléaires un peu sur
la fin non non ça vous dit pas je
travaillais à l'ukraine c'est une
question que vous apposez pardon on m'a
dit oui jancovici les lobbies pour l'udc
les airs vous confirmez vous infirmez je
ne sais pas ce que va dire lobbyistes
pour le est ce que vous êtes rémunérés
par des industries du nucléaire oui
carbone4 fait
je parcourais 5% de son chiffre
d'affaires avec edf mais j'ai écrit mes
premiers livres favorable au nucléaire
bien avant ça il faut les préparer pour
qu'ils vous donner un peu de sous il
faut leur donner confiance
non c'est pas ça j'ai toujours pensé
exactement ça sur le nucléaire
je les écris donc dans un livre qui
s'appelle l'avenir climatique en 2002
j'avais déjà expliqué que si on
s'attaquait à la question nucléaire avec
la même nationalité que celle qu'on
utilisait pour le climat la conclusion
pour moi était évidente c'est que on
était globalement mieux en en faisant
plus qu'en faisant moins un court ou
moyen terme
à long terme la 2000 à le surplus de co2
qu'on a déjà mis dans l'atmosphère
aujourd'hui si on arrêtait des maîtres
demain matin il faudrait attendre plus
de dix mille ans plus de dix mille ans
pour que l'atmosphère revienne à son
niveau initial
plus de dix mille ans donc je suis
désolé d'être un peu caricatural mais
j'en ai marre qu'on vienne me faire
chier avec des déchets nucléaires qui au
bout de quelques siècles
je parle bien des déchets hors plutonium
uns les autres au bout de quelques
siècles ils ont perdu l'essentiel de
leur radioactivité alors qu'avec le
changement climatique on est en train de
mettre en oeuvre à l'échelle de la terre
dans son ensemble quelque chose qui est
susceptible de déclencher la guerre
partout avec une réversibilité sur dix
vit l'enfer on n'est juste pas du tout
en train de parler de la même chose
pas du tout en train de parler de la
même chose le changement climatique il a
déjà contribué à mettre un million de
syriens en europe
je pense pas que les déchets nucléaires
aient fait ça le changement climatique
il a dit laissez pas déterminant direct
dans syrien oui oui le déclenchement de
la guerre en syrie doit quelque chose
aux sécheresses récurrentes qui ont
commencé à s'installer dans le pays et
qui ont fait décroître la production
agricole avec une population croissante
et ses traits fins et outlook et c'est
très exactement le même phénomène quand
on a eu au maghreb en egypte et en
tunisie
c'était plutôt axé sur l'augmentation du
plus de désir eu des hydrocarbures vers
2008 2009
lundi lens et les émeutes de la faim le
prix du pain qui explosent et angie oui
parce que l'egypte importe un quart de
ce qu'elles mangent parce que la tunisie
en importe la moitié parce que ces gens
là ont comme recettes à l'exportation
des touristes qui ont disparu en 2009 et
à cause de la crise énergétique que
j'évoquais juste avant donc ce qu'on est
en train d'observer autour de nous en
méditerranée
c'est déjà une expérience grandeur
nature en ce qui concerne les effets
désagréables de la crise énergétique et
du changement climatique
et là on est en train déjà de parler de
millions de personnes qui s'invite en
europe donc je ne pense pas que les
déchets nucléaires soit cet endroit là
en terme de nuisances voit la taxe
carbone taxe carbone aux frontières on
fait quoi pour faire plier un peu
l'allemagne ont fait des partenariats
avec keira faire plier l'allemagne est à
mon avis un exercice difficile à d'une
façon générale il faut bien voir que
l'allemagne on parlait du nucléaire
l'allemagne a choisie sur les dix
dernières années l'allemagne a choisi le
nucléaire c'est pire que le changement
climatique c'est très exactement ça
qu'ils ont choisi puisqu'ils ont dit on
va développer des énergies renouvelables
pour baisser duc les airs et charbon
s'en occupera derrière donc aujourd'hui
et puis l'allemagne commence à
comprendre que de diminuer à la fois le
nucléaire et le charbon ça va
contraindre à baisser
l'approvisionnement électrique et les
milieux économiques allemands n'ont
aucune envie de voir ça arrive et
consommateurs allemands je pas sûr qu'il
a bien compris mais les milieux
économiques allemands n'ont aucune envie
de voir ça arrivait donc le aujourd'hui
imposer une taxe carbone à l'allemagne
c'est un processus compliqué la seule
chose qui ait un peu de prise sur
l'allemagne c'est la morale il ya qu'à
voir comment est ce que les allemands
ont réagi quand les grecs les ont
traités de néo nazis en leur disant vous
voulez nous faire payer alors que
regarder et c'est des espèces de nazis
c'est le truc qui les a touchés et donc
il ya peut-être une voie une voie
d'accès à l'allemagne sur ce terrain là
mais c'est quand même pas que c'est pas
un combat gagné d'avancé
donc c'est pas un car et un combat gagné
d'avancé
je vais vous poser deux trois questions
qui on va finir parce que notre invité
est notre invité nous attend alstom
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ce qu'on peut imaginer pour alstom dont
qu'alstom avait deux métiers
alstom fabrique des trains fabriqués des
trains est fabriqué des centrales
électriques
alstom a eu un problème à mon avis j'ai
pas regardé les chiffres d'alstom dans
des terriens mais dans les business
d'alstom y avait un business qui
consistait à construire des centrales à
charbon ou à les maintenir
comme il ya quand même eu ces dernières
années un coup de frein sur
l'installation des centrales à charbon
on peut imaginer que alstom a souffert
de ça ensuite alstom installer des
centrales à gaz
là aussi il ya eu un sujet sur les
centrales à gaz en europe notamment
parce que l'essor des nerfs a conduit à
baisser la rentabilité des moyens
conventionnels centrales à gaz des
centrales à charbon
alstom fabriquer des turbines pour
centrales nucléaires
et là il ya un processus global de
défiance sauf dans deux pays qui sont la
russie ou iard cet homme est là et la
chine pardon où il ya maintenant de plus
en plus d'industriels chinois
enfin ou là où l'industrie chinoise est
en train de monter en puissance donc
alstom sur ses métiers historiques a été
frontalement attaquer et par ailleurs
alstom n'avait pas comme siemens le
marché domestique sur les éoliennes qui
a permis à siemens de développer une
ligne de business à l'exportation donc
il s'est passé ce qui s'est passé c'est
que alstom étant dans une situation
économique de plus en plus difficile a
fini par se vendre sur la partie train
gpad analyse vraiment parce que j'ai pas
regardé ça en détail avec carbone 4 vous
avez été chargée de faire un rapport sur
le troisième des landes on faisait un
petit peu envoyez du piment comme quoi
vous étiez en collusion avec nicolas
hulot
et ainsi de suite vous avez des trucs à
dire là dessus oui que je me suis fait
engueuler par nicolas hulot parce qu'on
l'avait pas prévenue que l'on
travaillait pour la médiation
donc ça veut dire que il n'a joué
absolument aucun rôle dans le fait qu'on
ait été choisie est en fait je peux vous
dire à qui on doit d'avoir été choisi
dans les trois membres de la médiation
il ya un homme s'appelle michel badré
qui est l'ancien président de l'autorité
environnementale qui est quelqu'un que
je connais depuis 15 ans qui est le
fonctionnaire le plus incorruptibles que
je connaisse et il est venu nous
chercher parce que il a considéré et je
suis d'accord avec lui que le carbone 4
n'avait plus de preuves a donné en ce
qui concerne le fait de calculer
correctement une empreinte carbone et
c'est très exactement ce qui nous
attendait et tout ce qui nous a demandé
de cesser tout un vote boutefeu touché
combien tout ce rapport 18000 euros très
exactement ce qui est une petite
commande pour nous c'est une petite
commande 18 millions vous préparez que
mon pour le changement climatique vous
avez pris des dispositions et une maison
à la campagne à titre personnel alors
j'ai lu avec intérêt le livre de pablo
cervinia sur l'effondrement est je me
suis pendant longtemps posé la question
de savoir si c'était justement pour en
revenir à nos discussions du début
l'américaine ou aof collapse qui était
le second c'est à dire je me bayne
qu'erich chez moi avec un an de boîtes
de conserve un fusil pour tirer sur tout
le monde
trois hectares de forêt pour avoir de
quoi se chauffer etc
et puis ce qui m'a toujours retenus dans
ce raisonnement c'est de me dire que
s'il ya cinquante personnes qui ont très
envie de venir zigouiller autour et de
venir taper mon bois et m'a fort à etc
je suis pas complètement sûr que tout
seul je ferai le point alors tout ça est
virtuel parce que j'envisage pas demain
matin de mettre dans une grotte est en
fait je j'ai été assez séduit par l'idée
avancée par palau serving dans son
bouquin que la bonne manière de se
préparer à une société qui commencent à
se disloquer c'est le réseau et la
solidarité
en fait quand on regarde les périodes
troublées
dans l'ancien temps alors certes les
gens qui étaient à la campagne pendant
la dernière guerre par exemple manger
mieux que les autres mais dans les
endroits qui étaient un peu un peu sous
pression
c'était les gens qui étaient capables de
sedan de s'organiser en réseau qui
survivaient mieux que les autres
donc pour le moment je me suis pas mis
dans une maison à la campagne avec mon
potager etc
mais c'est clairement un sujet sur
lequel ma réflexion est pas terminé de
savoir qu'elle est à titre personnel la
meilleure organisation dans une société
qui commence à se dernière question
parce que notre deuxième invité à des
impératifs
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
quelqu'un je sais plus qui un jour a dit
il ya c'est un mauvais arbitrage du
temps que de passer quand on a une heure
50 % du temps à poser un problème et 50%
du temps à le résoudre
en fait il vaut mieux passer 95% du
temps à poser le problème parce que
derrière on aura besoin que de 5 % du
temps pour le résoudre
donc dans la ligne de ce que j'ai
évoquées jusqu'à maintenant je crois que
sur ces problèmes qui sont des problèmes
nouveaux qui demandent des changements
conceptuels importants qui demandent de
bien comprendre de quoi on parle
qui demande d'être capable de bien faire
la différence entre ce qui va se
prolonger à l'avenir et ce qui ne peut
pas se prolonger à l'avenir j'ai envie
de dire que le premier conseil c'est de
bien comprendre la situation dans
laquelle on est parce que le métier que
je fais aujourd'hui on est la
conséquence tous les gens que j'ai vus
s'organiser d'une façon que je considère
être pertinente ils sont passés par
cette phase
donc ça ne donne pas la solution qui est
devenu jardinier données lager
devenez conducteurs de poids lourds
j'sais pas quoi par contre ça permet de
se forger sa propre opinion sur la façon
de piloter son avenir donc le premier
conseil que j'ai envie de donner c'est
documenté vous mais correctement
donc malheureusement passé l'étape des
les médias c'est pas suffisant essayez
de mettre la chose en cohérence et
attend que vous avez une réponse qui
n'est pas cohérente c'est que vous
n'avez pas fini
te comprendre donc faut continuer à
creuser héhéhé
méfiez-vous dans tout un tas de choses
dont la théorie du complot
moi ça m'a jamais les aider à avancer
donc essayé duquel dumas plusieurs bars
dont les ya plusieurs théories du
complot oui d'une manière générale que
et et vraiment je pense que le point
important c'est d'essayer de bien
comprendre ce qui est neuf
dans la situation actuelle parce que
tant qu'on n'est pas passé par là encore
une fois on voit pas ce qu'il faut
changer ce qu'il faut pas changer
j'entends djoko ici merci
[Musique]
il